le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines qui peut accueillir jusqu'à
6 le spectateur est le nouveau centre
d'entraînement de l'équipe de france et
de siège de la fédération française de
cyclisme à partir du 13 janvier il sera
également ouvert à tous grâce à des
activités variées
présentation
le vélodrome nationale c'est une
enceinte qui est toute récente aux
dernières technologies qui peut
accueillir jusqu à peu près 6000
spectateurs
déjà rien de ce pare-feu gabarit ça fait
un an soit une enceinte unique
ensuite il a une piste que vous pouvez
voir derrière qui est en elle-même
unique au monde puisqu'elle fait 250
mètres de long ce qui est la norme des
vélodromes internationaux mais elle fait
8 mètres de large donc ça c'est vraiment
un concept unique au monde et qui permet
aux athlètes d'atteindre des vitesses de
pointe beaucoup plus importante et donc
de battre des records
donc en soi le site est unique par sa
conception et puis par la conception de
sa piste
ma discipline sur le cyclisme sur piste
mais le spectre tout ce qui est vitesse
notamment à plusieurs fois champion du
monde en vitesse par équipes
on en est d'ailleurs en vitesse
individuelle et puis médaillé d'argent
jozan un pic de non droit en vitesse et
vitesse par équipes
qu'est ce qu'on pensait de ce vélodrome
national l'as rome est détectée gens
pensent qu'il y bien que libé on se fait
plaisir de gestion des dons comme ça
qu'ils sont et pas de changement petit
flic tout est fluide tout est fluide et
évoluer sur la piste facilement ou
comment basé pas peur de descendre ou
monter des fois on est mature ces
petites craintes il descendait trop vite
et trop de chasser un peu de barrières
l'a énoncé impression de rouler sur du
plat tout simplement non c'est en tout
cas c'est un très bel outil voit les
séances d'entraînement on doit pouvoir
dont ça s'amuser tout en forçant
dans un partenaire public privé en fin
de compte on délègue à un constructeur
est un opérateur en fin de compte qu'un
groupement on délègue un sens rentrer
deux choses d'abord la construction et
ensuite la gestion
le choix qu'on a fait dans cette
démarche c'est d'avoir une entité
complète qui allait construire mais
aussi gérer donc il ya une vision en fin
de compte de deux du constructeur pour
que la gestion soit optimum ça c'était
la première des démarches après il était
évident que dans ce partenariat on
devait retrouver des équilibres
économiques
c'est vrai que ce partenariat public
privé d'abord il a été mûrement
réfléchie par
le comité de pilotage que je présidais
où il y avait élu état région
département ce partenariat a été
équilibré il a été cadré au niveau
financier s'apprêter facile tous les
jours mais aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
dépensé un centime de plus ce qui était
prévu et en plus le travail qui a été
fait tant avec vélopolis des équipes de
bouygues mais aussi la fédération
française de cyclisme a amené à ce
qu'aujourd'hui cet équipement soit
opérationnel à la date prévue
c'est-à-dire le 13 décembre 2013
je m'occupe en gestion de toute la
filière bmx et donc sélectionneur
l'équipe de france
pour nous c'est un ensemble complexe
déjà qui est magnifique attendant la
structure que pour l'accueil et le
développement de la discipline qu'on
peut y faire notamment je parle du bmx
donc la piste de bmx le fait qu'elle
soit qu'elles soient couvertes qui perd
de sa permettra de rouler en permanence
dessus on à la proximité avec avec la
piste et les locaux la salle de
musculation les la cellule de
récupération le bureau de la fédé c'est
creux même pas anodin non plus parce que
des fois c'est quand même plus pratique
d'aller voir les gens en direct c'est
évident que pour nous c'est une chance
inouïe d'être de se retrouver rassemblés
sur ce site et que c'est ça va être le
je pense le démarrage d'une grande
aventure pour nous
magali pauthier 24 ans pratique le bmx
championne du monde en 2012 et finaliste
olympique également en 2012 et plusieurs
fois championne de france championne
d'europe et championne du monde
je pense que c'est vraiment une superbe
structure qui permet de réunir voilà
tous les pistards les routes 1 et les
bmx ensemble de créer une nouvelle
dynamique une émulation groupe
et
alan et le bâtiment il accueillera la
fédération française de cyclisme son
pôle administratif et ses athlètes nous
aurons à peu près 60 athlètes de
l'équipe de france qui seront logés et
nourris
juste à côté du vélodrome et qui
s'entraîneront ici quotidiennement
et puis la complexité du bâtiment et son
caractère encore une fois unique et que
ce bâtiment est ouvert au grand public
donc quotidiennement 7 jours sur 7 le
grand public peuvent avoir accès à la
piste des professionnels bien entendu
selon des créneaux de disponibilité un
petit peu particulier mais peut aussi
venir faire du bmx du badminton du
fitness et d'autres types d'activités
sportives ouvertes à tous
notre objectif en tant qu'exploitant il
est d'inscrire pleinement le vélodrome
au sein du territoire et que chaque
habitant aux salariés du territoire
puissent s'approprier
donc effectivement le grand public peut
venir mais également les entreprises que
ce soit lors des événements compétition
cyclisme autres ou lors de séminaires
congrès qui souhaitent organiser
directement pour leur part leur
compagnie vélodrome est construit pour
avoir une mission numéro unique et le
centre national du cyclisme donc il va
accueillir l'ensemble des compétitions
nationales et internationales qui seront
produites ou coproduite par la
fédération française de cyclisme
mais dans le cadre de l'éclectisme
la mission de service public que l'on
doit aux territoires vélopolis en tant
que exploitants s'engagent à organiser
une certes un certain nombre
d'événements donc d'autres activités
physiques et sportives que vous voyez
dans l'air centrale ici on peut
accueillir du badminton du volet du
basket du handball du judo bref tout à
une somme de sport indoor et qui est
susceptible d'attirer jusqu'à 6000
personnes
et puis après sur le volet culturel nous
avons prévu d'organiser quelques
concerts des spectacles comiques
bref toute une tout un éclectisme de
programmation de façon à ce que chacun
puisse au moins une fois dans l'année
venir découvrir un spectacle au
vélodrome c'est évident que pour saint
quentin en yvelines pour le territoire
pour les entreprises pour ses habitants
le vélodrome va être une magnifique
locomotive du coc motive médiatique mais
aussi un lieu culturel qui va permettre
à la population de pouvoir avoir sur
place
une salle qui est du niveau des lycées
la deuxième salle d'ile-de-france et le
rayonnement de ce vélodrome à
l'international va profiter à l'image du
territoire
la première grande date sera le 13
janvier date d'ouverture au grand public
pour les activités quotidiennes sportive
le 1er et 2 février à des portes
ouvertes où on le seront présentent
également des démonstrations de cyclisme
sur piste avec l'équipe de france mais
aussi des autres activités sportives et
là ce sera gratuit et ouvert à tous
prochaines dates après dès le 8 février
une compétition régionale
et puis ensuite la plus grosse
compétition qui arrive le plus gros
événement qui arrive tout de suite c'est
le 14 et 15 mars
coupe de france de bmx et puis ensuite
nous
un championnat de france de bmx en
juillet une deuxième coupe de france de
bmx en octobre et un championnat de
france sur piste plus beaucoup d'autres
événements de ce qui est aujourd'hui une
trentaine d'événements qui sont déjà
dans le pacte pour 2014 et manon vous en
connaissez avions sur le vélo et
maintenant ils étudient mois
et le début de ses actus par une info
transports vous retrouverez vos
nouvelles fiches horaires des l'cie
janvier dans les bus garé mairie et
bâtiments publics ainsi qu'à l' agence
de la mobilité et sur le site internet
www.caf.fr sache se déplacer sachez
aussi qu'en ce début d'année vous
bénéficierez très prochainement d'une
nouvelle gare routière sur l'avenue paul
delouvrier réalisé par la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la communauté
d'agglo la casse qui continue sa lutte
contre les plantes invasives et
particulièrement contre la renault est
du japon qui malgré sa beauté est une
vraie menace pour la biodiversité
puisque elles dégradent les écosystèmes
arrachage des plans traitements
phytosanitaires fauchage répéter village
ou encore retrait des terres contaminées
bâchage mêmes injection à la seringue ou
nuit le service environnement espaces
verts ne chôme pas et long terme on
dirait que tu avec un bon plan la
nouvelle expo de l'office de tourisme
qui s'installera dans ses locaux à
partir du 6 janvier
en retraçant l'histoire des eaux du
château de versailles vous découvrirez
comment le réseau d'étangs et rigolent
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines alimentait
les bassins du fameux roi soleil et bien
sûr c'est gratuit un dossier que vous
pouvez retrouver dans le critique
atteint du mois de janvier ainsi qu'un
article sur un athlète de haut niveau
babacar diop et un article sur de drôles
d'instruments de musique qui aura
bientôt et ben ali
site un article sur la tête de haut
niveau ben oui également
aujourd'hui le gamin était coire